Do you think Chinese acupuncture has any value for balancing body systems?
Yes, I do. I so Chinese acupuncture
Some people say, well, that's a religious art. No, it's not. So Chinese acupuncture has nothing to do with their religion
Their belief system. It's not Buddhist. It's not Hindu. It's not any of that
Um, it is simply helping balancing the energy up. That's where people in the past. I mean, I've done acupuncture and by practice since I graduated 1986 so I graduated doing acupuncture. I took acupuncture classes in school. I did acupuncture a lot on people. So um, it it it is has it is not a religious connotation in acupuncture versus you could maybe make that argument with
them with other things like um, different practices that you may want to stay away from acupuncture has been given a bit
Kind of title, especially back in the 70s when initially it was kind of brought over to the United States because it talks about energy and because you can't dissect the meridian. So it describes these
These basically portals of energy cross your body that are described in Chinese acupuncture as meridians
That are separate from anatomical structures like nerves. So because the medical profession could dissect these meridians. They said they don't exist. Well
There's there's nobody in the medical profession
Um, except some ancient doctors that believe that anymore. It's very
measurable now with instrumentation. You can measure its meridian flow
And um, you can't argue with it. Does it help? Yeah, I think it can help a lot. Does it mean you need to do it? No, I don't think you need to do it
I think your body can balance that yourself. I think your blockages in those energy can have to do a lot with
Your your metabolic health a lot with your chemical health, which would be your nutrition and such
Give you a lot with your attitude and your thought process and your prayer life
So when I do think there's value in acupuncture